the last time that we saw rainbow at the
end of Rainbow six siege they were
leaving a decontamination shelter and
cheering a pretty bad understanding of
how biological warfare works you're just
gonna put that rifle down wash off and
then pick it right back up again
that's probably why this next thing
happened in the first place all right
color run
oh so it's no leap to find out that an
unhygenic outbreak is coming to Rainbow
six siege on March 6th this will be the
first new co-op mode since launch and
here's everything you should know so far
all right let's do the high-level stuff
March 6 year 3 for Rainbow six siege is
gonna kick off with operation chimera on
ps4 Xbox one and PC it's gonna bring two
new operators who are both bioweapons
experts make sense given the theme whose
names are Lian a French operator and
vinca a Russian operator their gadgets
will likely be a drone that quarantines
the perimeter and nanobots that may give
speed boosts or heal but more
importantly let's talk about what we
know about outbreak outbreak started off
being teased in an alternate reality
game that implicated Russians a
government conspiracy and a pandemic
these dead drops are being handed out by
the manifest destiny militia who were
smuggling the info out and definitely
did not trust the feds or FEMA some of
these notes indicate that the government
was suspiciously prepared for this event
the militia made claims of a false flag
event where government forces make an
excuse to take over a part of America
the National Guard is sent in and then
shortly thereafter the president's plane
is attacked and grounded with Russian
hackers being the suspects this all
devolves in a series of notes with the
National Guard ending up shooting people
an outbreak and the town being
quarantined
the next piece of info came from the
space capsule trailer in this we see
what's probably a manifest destiny
militia member entering a compound to
find a Russian satellite that his
buddies hauled into his bunker the
windows busted out on the satellite and
what we now know escaped was the apex
extraterrestrial parasite this may give
light on why Russian hackers grounded
the u.s. president's plane and may have
been trying to hide their involvement
after that the ashes call to arms
trailer shows units being overrun by the
outbreak ash wants to go in with some
select operators in the Russians in
order to find out what's happening
whether she already knows about the
Russian involvement
he's colluding with them or doesn't know
it all is kind of uncertain at this
point all this points to rainbow
snagging their elite operators and going
to investigate speaking of not all
operators will be in co-op the ones
confirmed so far are Leon finca smoke
yang buk kapkan ash doc de chunka
finally a good use for this poor bastard
glass and the recruits this operator
list makes a lot of sense because these
are characters who can heal snipe deny
an area with gas pulled down on Lena
with a light machine gun or laid or
traps
so in summary outbreak is a four-week
co-op event that runs march 6 to April
3rd it should be on the test servers
though on February 20th the location is
truth or consequence in New Mexico there
will be three exclusive co-op maps that
are set to be bigger than those in
situations or terrorist hunt the enemy
is an extraterrestrial parasite named
apex there are different kinds of
creatures you can see here in this image
one looks like a tripod a dog a dead
space ripoff possibly a defensive tower
and some kind of brute we know the virus
spreads Underground through crystalline
structures that are up from the earth
characters are said to have to make
smart use of barricades and
fortifications leading us to wonder if
there won't be some kind of buying or
building mechanic like classic horde
mode finally movie soft is teased that
we'll learn more at invitationals on
February 18th and 19th and we'll
probably be able to talk more about it
then now outbreak does have some
controversy around loot boxes the loot
crate's are called outbreak packs and
there are 50 of them containing cosmetic
items Ubisoft has said that if you buy
them you won't get duplicates they're
about 300 Rainbow six siege credits each
the cheapest you can buy them is about
two for $5 there was an initial
announcement that the standard $40
Edition was going to be scrapped and
replaced with a $60 advance
addition the new addition was going to
include ten outbreak packs fans who got
the game to where it is today we're a
bit upset that they were not going to
get the outbreak packs after having
already paid full price for the game and
shelling out for each season
Ubisoft backpedaled after the gamer
outraged keeping the $40 standard
edition intact but also keeping the $60
$90 and 130 dollar versions so you're
looking forward to zombie like creatures
in siege well that chunk I finally be
good at something feel free to discuss
either in the comments below will likely
have more to tell you around the
official announcement Ubisoft tease for
February 18th or 19th and will
definitely show you outbreak on the test
servers if it goes live it is planned on
February 20th thanks for watching what
about nuke in the town what would be the
first time we used a nuke in New Mexico
you